Speaker 1: If you thought it was wild and
unprecedented when Donald Trump attacked his
own former Vice President Mike Pence for not
trying to. Overturn an election that he lost.
That is nothing compared with what Donald
Trump did yesterday. Clearly enamored with
Vladimir Putin and remember, Trump has said
he has fallen in love with dictators before.
Speaker 3: And then we fell in love.
Speaker 1: Right? That was about Kim Jong UN.
Trump, enamored with Vladimir Putin yesterday
called genius Putin's invasion of Ukraine,
using the pretext of recognizing the independence
of those two regions. Smart and savvy guys,
Trump is in love. Trump is in love. He
loves Putin, and he loves the invasion.
Trump appeared yesterday on the Clay Travis and
Buck Sexton show. I don't know what that is,
but Trump clearly doing lots of right wing
shows. And here is what he had to say,
and he's just smitten with Vladimir Putin.
Speaker 3: We know Russia has said that they
are recognizing two breakaway regions
of Ukraine, and now this White House is
stating that this is an invasion. That's a strong
word. What went wrong here? What is the current
occupant of the Oval Office done that he
could have done differently? Well, what
went wrong was a rigged election. So first of all,
Speaker 1: there is no question that Trump can
answer without mentioning the big
lie that he actually won. OK, so
but that's not what we're going to focus today.
Speaker 3: And what went wrong is a candidate
that shouldn't be there and a man that has
no concept of what he's doing. I went in
yesterday and there was a television
screen and I said, This is genius,
Putin declares. A big portion of the Ukraine of
Ukraine. Putin declares it as independent. Oh,
that's wonderful. So Putin is now saying it's
independent. A large section of Ukraine. I said,
How smart is that? And he's going
to go in and be a peacekeeper.
Speaker 1: He is smitten. Now, some of you have
pointed out Trump sort of seems to be using a tone
that suggests he recognizes the cynical nature
of what Putin is doing. And I agree. I agree.
Trump sees what Putin is doing, but he still is so
impressed. I'm not saying he likes it, but he's so
impressed with how Putin has done this.
Speaker 3: That's the strongest piece for
us. We could use that on our southern border.
That's the strongest peace force I've ever
seen. There were more army tanks than I've ever
seen, and they're going to keep peace. All right.
But think of it. Here's a guy who's very savvy.
I know him very savvy. Very well. Very, very
well. By the way, this never would have happened
with us had I been in office. Not even thinkable,
this would never have happened. But here's a
guy that says, you know, I'm going to declare
a big portion of Ukraine independent. He used
the word independent. And we're going to go out
and we're going to go in and we're going to help
keep peace. You got to say that's pretty savvy.
Speaker 1: So Trump, of course, an undertone of
what Putin is doing, I would not have allowed
it to happen. But he is just in love with Vladimir
Putin. Can you imagine what Fox News and the other
Republicans would be doing if Biden or some other
Democratic leader called what Putin was doing?
Genius, smart, savvy. Trump is basically saying
Putin is super smart and this is all genius, and
it never would have happened if I was in the White
House. But it is incredible that this guy was so
brilliant that he was able to do this. And by the
way, with with a lot of these right wingers, it is
incredible how they are very soft on the violation
of Ukraine's border integrity by Russia while
saying, Oh my God, when it comes to the US-Mexico
border, we've got to have a border, we've got to
enforce it. There is nothing more sacrosanct
than the US-Mexico border, but the Ukraine
Russia border. It's sort of up to Putin's opinion
where where that should be incredible. This guy
just loves these authoritarian, dictatorial
autocrats, and you can hear it in his voice.
You can hear it in his voice. There's a little
bit of sarcasm and there's a little bit of like,
Wow, what what? How audacious. But it is
a guy who is genuinely impressed with the
things Vladimir Putin is doing is that it's not
a surprise. It's not a surprise if you're hearing
something different in Trump's voice there. Let
me know you can find me on Twitter at De Packman.
The David Pakman Show is an independent viewer
and listener supported program I would love
for you to sign up at join Packman dot com. We
do a lot for our members, including producing
a daily additional show for you, called the
bonus show. Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want to
make money and everybody else it makes money to
fund themselves is bad, right?
Speaker 1: He even calls
it predatory.
Speaker 3: That is a
frickin predator right there, right?
Speaker 1: If there is any better
endorsement of the bonus show, it's
that Alex Jones is so angry about it.
And you can sign up at Join Pacman Dot Com.
You'll also get The Daily Show six hours before
everybody else with no commercials. So there are
many perks to membership at Join Pacman dot com